I'm the operations manager here at
politics and prose and I'm actually not
here as much to introduce as to stand
here in case to kind of be the body
double to kinda be the first guy the
limo in case somebody's going to take a
shot it's actually in Jon Ronson's
contract that we do have to have that
here when when we first started talking
about after the you know John had agreed
to come here and we were talking about
it one of the owners of the star and I'm
not going to mention who had had a bit
of a fit claiming that this was pretty
much one of the worst ideas for a novel
she had ever heard of and the events
coordinator and I both of both of whom
had read them and I had already had a
galley in my hand an advance copy of it
and was reading it started to explain to
her that it it wasn't fiction and it
took a kid you not a good 25 minutes to
finally convince her and actually had to
put the book in her hand to convince her
of that and it occurred to me then that
if this was fiction it would have a more
unbelievable than The Da Vinci Code in
the sense heroines like boo
it is Dan Brown here as in in the sense
that it's it's amazing and it's amazing
up until you start to kind of put
certain things in context when you start
to remember the hundred thousand dollar
toilet seat when you start to remember
some of these things and it kind of all
lines up and I think the best story
about this book this afternoon I've read
it and a number of my floor managers
have read it as well
and one of them came up to me probably
an hour ago and it's like when when can
you give Jon Ronson a note I have it in
my pocket
and as justifiably skeptical and then he
told me that Colonel Alexander who
appears in the book had called the store
this afternoon and said have John send
me a signed copy
and so it's amazed by the fact that that
they tracked him down and it turns out
yo was a message yeah yeah basically and
since then when we came in someone else
who's in the book is in the audience and
it's a little bit like Old Home Week
here so without further ado it's my
distinct pleasure to welcome tonight's
author a filmmaker and an author who we
dearly dearly love here at politics and
prose and we in fact need more of these
books jon ronson I can ask Simon &
Schuster to ship you some more copies of
the books um the men who stare at goats
really begins with my first book them
and and if you'll indulge me because
I've done so few readings from them in
the u.s. in fact one I'm going to read a
little bit from it first because I think
it will explain a little bit about me
and about why I ended up writing the men
who stare at goats then then was a book
really about leaders of militant groups
Islamic fundamentalists I spent a year
with a man called Omar Bakri Mohammed
who called himself a Salman bin Laden's
man and Great Britain although I'd
noticeably to stop calling himself that
on September the 12th 2001 I spent a
year with him and I spent a lot of time
with her with a Ku Klux Klan leader who
had banned his members from using the
n-word and he banned the robes and the
hoods and kind of banned everything that
was presumably fun about being in the Ku
Klux Klan and he'd replaced all those
things with personality skills seminar
workshops all the Klansmen had to decide
if there were sanguine or flag Mattox I
was a phlegmatic and I thought that
these people really had nothing much in
common but it turned out that they did
have something in common they all
believed
much as like Osama bin Laden believes
and Eric Rudolph and Timothy McVeigh
that there was a shadowy cabal secretly
ruling the world from inside a secret
room and they also were telling me this
stuff and I'd IV I put it out of my mind
but then I just kept hearing it from
Muslim fundamentalists and from
neo-nazis so finally I said well tell me
more about this shadowy cabal and I said
I wanna call the Bilderberg Group and
they always meet once a year in a five
star hotel with golfing facilities and
that's where they secretly rule the
world and I said what do you know where
they meet lisanova there's a man called
big jim tucker he knows he lives in
Washington DC so I phoned up Jim Tucker
works for a newspaper called the
spotlight he'd made it his life's work
to track down the shadowy cabal I phoned
him out purred and I said is it true and
he said yes and you've caught me at a
good time I've discovered that the
Bilderberg Group were meeting at the end
of May beginning of June at the Caesar
Park Hotel and golfing Resort in Sintra
Portugal and I fully intend to fly over
there climb at the drainpipes get in and
confront them red-handed going about
their covert wickedness so I said can I
come it said yes you can as long as you
don't step on twigs when were on the
prowl so we flew to Portugal and I
really thought it was nothing I thought
it was a shaggy dog story but we went to
the Caesar Park Hotel I dutifully
followed and we scouted around China
formed contacts with waitresses this was
the day before the shadowy cabal was
supposedly arriving and I was going to
read a little bit from the book of what
happened just after we scouted around
the hotel this is my telephone call to
the bishop embassy mm-hmm I'm a
journalist from London I said I'm
calling on the road from sintra to
Estoril and being tailed right now by a
dark green Lancia belonging to the
Bilderberg Group
there was a sharp intake of breath go on
she said I'm sorry I said but I just
heard you take a sharp breath bilderberg
she said yes I said they watched her
scouting around the Caesar Park Hotel
and they've been following us ever since
we have now been followed for three
hours I wasn't sure at first so I
stopped my car on the side of a deserted
Lane
and he stopped his car right in front of
us can you imagine just how chilling
that moment was this is especially
disconcerting because I'm from England
and I'm not used to being spied on
do you have bilderberg's permission to
be in Portugal she said do they know
you're here no I said Bilderberg are
very secretive she said they don't want
people looking into their business what
are you doing here I am essentially a
humorous journalist I explained I am a
humorous journalist out of my depth do
you think it might help if we tell them
that from the corner of my eye I saw Jim
wind down his window he leant his head
out and blue and antagonizing lady like
kiss at the Lancia hold on a second I
said Jim I said sternly please stop that
I lowered my voice I'm here with an
American I said called big jim tucker
he's a national provocateur that might
be the problem maybe you can phone
Bilderberg and explain this I may be in
the car with Jim Tucker but I'm not
actually with him listen she said
urgently Bilderberg is much bigger than
we are we're very small with just a
little embassy
do you understand they're way out of our
league all I can say is go back to your
hotel and sit tight this is what
happened when we got back to the hotel
Sandra from the British Embassy called
me on my cell phone to inform me that
she'd spoken to the Bilderberg office at
the Ceasar Park and they said that
nobody was following us and how could
they call off someone who didn't exist
he is I said in a staccato whisper
behind the tree
the good news said Sandra is if you know
you're being followed they're probably
just trying to intimidate you the
dangerous ones would be those you don't
know of following you but this was scam
comfort what if these men were the
dangerous ones I just happened to be
naturally good at spotting them what if
I was adept at this so it surprised me
just how easily I slid into their bubble
of illogicality because really when you
think about it I was being chased by a
couple of security guards in dark
glasses admittedly who were there to
protect a think-tank meeting of powerful
industrialists and bankers I shouldn't
have been so surprised but instantly I
began to think that it's true the crazy
people are right onto something and I
slid into this bubble and within this
bubble of logical or made absolute
to me I became one of the paranoid
people and then when I began to
investigate these cabal's
I discovered that they were basically
nuts as well they all go to this place
called Bohemian Grove in Northern
California where they have these insane
rituals where people like George Bush
and Dick Cheney and Henry Kissinger
dress up in robes and hoods and have a
kind of mock human sacrifice where were
a papier-mache effigy is thrown into the
fiery belly of a 50-foot stone owl which
we secretly filmed and put out on
British TV and it was nuts when I was
there with a with a right-wing
conspiracy theorists who believed this
was evidence of actual child sacrifice
and I came or I think it was basically
just a pageant and the worst thing about
it was that it was just so immature but
nonetheless the people who attended the
rituals seemed to take them just as
seriously as the conspiracy theorists
did and I thought about that and I
wondered whether under Clinton the
paranoid and crazy people were very much
marginalized they were in the woods in
the Ozark Mountains and so on but then
when Bush gone into Paris September the
11th I began to wonder whether these
bubbles of illogicality existed within
powerful places too and that was the
question that set me on the road to
writing the men who stare at goats and
it really began about two weeks after
September the 11th when I had lunch with
Uri Geller I I just remembered Uri
Geller after 9/11 because he'd always
spoken about how he had been a secret
psychic spy working for the CIA in the
1970s and he'd tell people this all the
time and the journalists would you know
report what he said and then add
sarcastic asides but I wondered whether
maybe there was something in it so I
phoned him up we had a little bit of a
rocky relationship me you know eagle I
didn't if I should tell you I didn't put
it in the book
but there's a backstory will I tell you
the backstory okay what about ten years
ten years ago you were Geller announced
that he knew
the Lost Ark of the Covenant was buried
and he was going to dig it up and
although I was a little concerned about
you know when they started digging you
know we have to avert our eyes list
would be turned to dust has IRA might be
good fun to go along so I found him up
and I said you mind if I come too and we
arranged to meet at his home in Sonning
on Thames and as I pulled into his
village my cell phone rang I was about
an hour early and the voice said John is
early if you haven't left your house yet
I was wondering could you bring along
and I said earlier it's funny you should
phone I've actually just pulled up in
your village I know he said I knew it
I could feel it that's why I phoned
shippi didn't I say I could feel John in
the village and I heard shippi his
brother-in-law yes you did who V and I
wrote this F at the time Leah's rather
cross and but he agreed to meet me for
lunch and I've done a little bit of
search about the the psychic spies and
it turned out that we really had been
tested by the CIA
but it was kind of weird in the
restaurant he was wearing big wraparound
mirrored sunglasses two weeks after 9/11
every time a plane flew overhead we all
looked up hmm and I said early tell me
about your days as a psychic spy he said
I don't talk about it I never talk about
it and I said early I've got a file an
inch-thick
of you talking about it and then
suddenly he took off his sunglasses and
he looked me squarely in the eye if you
repeat what I'm about to tell you he
said I will deny it okay I said it would
be your word against mine
said early okay I said he moved his
chair closer to mine he glanced around
the restaurant this he said is no longer
a history story I'm sorry I said I have
been reactivated said early what I said
I looked over at Shipley he nodded
gravely early I said please give me
something to go on please tell me one
more thing early side okay he said I
will tell you one more thing only the
man who reactivated me is called wrong
that was it wouldn't tell me anything
else
when tell me have Ron was CIA or FBI so
I decided to go on a journey to find Ron
and I never found Iran but what I did
found was something a lot order and it
was this in 1995 the CIA Declassified
the fact that they had a crack team of
secret psychic spies it sounded
incredibly glamorous but it wasn't so
glamorous it was basically half a dozen
soldiers sitting inside a condemned
clapboard building at Fort Meade
Maryland told by their commanding
officers to try and be psychic and I
basically stayed in there for 23 years
and because they were black up with no
you know they didn't exist
they had no coffee machine and you can
imagine after 23 years I would really
rank all they had to bring their own
coffee into work and they never they
never got repairs done you know on their
building because they didn't exist
buildings supposed to be empty anyway
the CIA kind of Declassified and shut
them down in ignorant of me in 1995 and
everybody went crazy
for them you know the crack team of
psychic spies and nobody really thought
maybe this was the tip of an iceberg and
it turned out it was and the iceberg is
what I wrote about of the men who stare
at goats and it turns out that there was
a secret team of soldiers at Fort Bragg
in North Carolina who had a hundred
goats the goats had all been depleted
not so that the soldiers would need to
learn how to cauterize the vocal cords
of the enemy which I don't think is
something that you know could be
deployable in a combat situation but
because they didn't want the local and
more rights activists finding out that
they had goats on base so the goats were
just standing there with their mouths
opening and closing with no bleat coming
out many of them had their legs in
plaster this is because they'd been shot
in the leg and then nursed back to
health in regular conventional medical
training programs from time to time the
goats would all be herded into a room
and then subdued throw in a hand grenade
and then it all Russian and you know and
try and nurse the goats back to health
terrible things are done to goats in the
US military is the mole of this but if
that wasn't bad enough in the early
1980s and once again today once they had
all these goats on base special forces
decided to try and kill them just by
staring at them so they started staring
they got in martial arts experts from
around America including a man called
Guy savelii in Ohio and they basically
just stared at the goats I managed to
track down guys savelii the goats tear
it was Colonel Alexander who eerily
found this store this afternoon and told
me about him I phoned him and I said is
it true did you ever manage to kill a
goat just by staring at it
he said yes it's true I said I don't
suppose she still practice the technique
to you said yep
he said only last week I killed my
hamster just by staring at it and he
said he said he'd videoed it and I could
come and watch the video if I wanted to
so I turned up at his martial arts and
dance studio in Ohio he showed me all
the documentation of him at Special
Forces at Fort Bragg
photographs of soldiers corine in the
act of karate chopping goats to death
with the quivering palm which his
martial arts technique where apparently
you walk around for 24 hours and then
drop dead and then he showed me his
hamster video he was very suspicious of
me actually he did they were looking and
him and his son were filming me the
whole time I was there and they wouldn't
they thought and turns out they thought
I was Al Qaeda well when I phoned they
cut I thought well you know how do we
know he's not al-qaeda so they phoned up
Special Forces and he said there's this
guy you know claims to be a journalist
from England he might be al Qaeda
Special Forces I said to him meet him
philbin send us the film we want to know
what he looks like and I think I've
pinpointed at what moment guys savelii
realized that I wasn't al Qaeda and is
when I discovered that his daughter had
danced with Richard Gere in the movie
Chicago and I kind of screeched you know
I loved Catherine zeta-jones in that
movie
and I kind of figured that even a
deep-cover al Qaeda operative wouldn't
think to go that effeminate um so that
was the moment the guy relaxed so he
showed me the hamster video now on one
level this is basically a hamster in its
wheel with a guy staring at it and
providing like an entirely random
psychic narrative to this to this to
listening because it is look it's have
you ever seen a hamster act like that I
don't own a hamster I've never owned a
hamster I do not know how they behave I
do not know if whether or not it was
abhorrent behavior it did stand very
very still for a long time at one point
than the other hamster which was the
control hamster climbed on top of it and
I kept on saying to guy am I going to um
Michael to see it die now yeah just wait
just wait to gets weirder it gets
weirder and then the tape ended just as
the goat just as the hamster gets up and
brushes itself down and starts eating so
it's a very inconclusive video later guy
told me that the reason why he didn't
want me to see the bits where the
hamster actually dies is because he was
afraid I was a bleeding-heart liberal
and would take it out of context
but he assured me that the hamster did
die more recently a few months ago I got
a very excited telephone call from guy
savelii he'd had a call from Special
Forces because the goat and the hamster
staring experiments had taken place in
the early 1980s around 1982 1983 but in
2004 guy was found out of the blue from
Special Forces and they wanted him to go
down to Fort Bragg with an animal master
I said two guys at a goat and he said no
and I said what kind of animal was it he
said I'm not going to tell you and I
said was it a small animal cheap to
purchase guy said yes I said was it a
hamster guy said I can neither confirm
nor deny that turns out that the reason
why they're doing the staring again now
is because they don't a killer hamster
anymore what they want to do is learn
the art of the stare that if you can
really freak out
a hamster that he can really freak out a
subject of interrogation at a prison
camp in Iraq so they're teaching the
interrogators the art of the stare with
guy savelii back in the 80s they were
trying to actually kill them and at one
point by guys account see all the videos
are inconclusive each time you know
you've got have you've got a goat
strapped up to an ECG machine the camera
zooms into the machine you hear a
soldier off-camera saying he's down but
the cabmen if it pans out again so you
never see it so even though I've seen
three video shot at Fort Bragg with
these experiments I've never actually
seen any animal fall over but at one
point apparently they put 30 goats in a
room they put numbers on each of the
goats guy was staring at goat number 16
and goat number 17 fell over which I
guess is collateral damage
so obviously I was curious to know how
all this came to be and it turns out it
was all because of one man a remarkable
and really quite wonderful
lieutenant-colonel called Jim Channon
Jim was in Vietnam and he realized that
his men were being killed because they
impulsively and kind-hearted ly fired
high missing the enemy they just weren't
cunning the Vietcong they were cunning
but not the Americans and so after the
Vietnam War Jim wrote to the Pentagon he
said he wanted to teach the American
army how to be more cunning and would
they fund him on a two-year Odyssey
where he would learn these things so the
Pentagon agreed and Jim spent two years
in California amongst the emerging New
Age human potential communities of
California he never told them how the
ideas that he was picking up there in
his naked hottub encounter sessions and
so on could be adapted to teach a
battlefield soldier how to be more
cunning but after two years he came back
with a manual and it was called the
first Earth battalion operations manual
and it was a redesign of every aspect of
military life in the first Earth
battalion soldiers would carry baby
lambs into hostile countries and they'd
place the Lambs down on the ground and
with sparkly eyes they'd give the enemy
an automatic hug now if that wasn't
enough to pacify the enemy the soldiers
would have loudspeakers attached to
their uniforms and these loudspeakers
would emit indigenous music and words at
peace and if that wasn't enough the
music would then be switched to
broadcast discordant sounds like acid
rock music out of synch as we know from
recent events the idea of blasting
detainees with discordant sounds is is
one of Jimi's legacies very much alive
today they're blasting Barney the purple
dinosaur at insurgents in our crime and
Fleetwood Mac and Metallica and so on so
that's one of Jim's legacies it's alive
today in the war on terror
anyway the Pentagon was was my guess is
that at any other time
they would have laughed him out at the
room but I think it wasn't just
individual soldiers who were traumatized
after Vietnam I think they the Army is a
machine was melancholy and in a funk and
just wanted to be comforted by something
it was nice and they really embraced
jim's ideas they instantly offered him
the chance to set up a real first Earth
battalion where soldiers one of Jimmy's
biggest ideas was that soldiers would
learn how to pass through walls they
could learn how to walk through walls so
they offered Jim the opportunity to to
try and get soldiers to do that but Jim
said no Jim was Jim was kind of a
pragmatist and he realized that these
ideas were good on paper but you have
not necessarily achievable in real life
he said no he wanted his manual to float
out there and wherever it took root that
person would be a member of the first
Earth battalion and because the Army is
full of I mean I think Jim wanted people
to strive for the impossible but find a
greater level of human potential but
because so many of Jim's superiors were
literal minded men they actually tried
to walk through their walls and the men
who stare at goats opens with general
Stubblebine the third the commander of
military intelligence between 1980 and
1983 getting up from behind his desk and
jogging to his wall he's thinking to
himself what is the Atem mostly made up
of space not only the keyword Ernest is
mostly what am I mostly made up of atoms
all have to do is merged the spaces the
wall is an illusion am i destined to
stay in this room no bang bumped his
nose and he was confounded by his
continual failure to pass through his
wall and he eventually went to Special
Forces at Fort Bragg he kind of thought
he had too much in his injury being
commander of Army Intelligence to do
this so you know maybe Special Forces
would be able to do it and it was he who
put into Special Forces the idea that
they should try and kill animals just by
staring at them so that was know that's
how the first Earth battalion that's how
this think tank idea floated into the
fabric of the military you know the
general Stubblebine was moved by the
manual
he went to Fort Bragg
he suggested it to Fort Bragg Faubourg
tried it out and then in the early
eighties it kind of died down excuse me
but obviously I was fascinated to know
how these ideas live on today in the war
on terror and the second half of the
book is my journey to try and find that
out and I'm going to read one little bit
from the book because I met a man called
Pete brew so Pete trains martial arts he
changed the Marines and martial arts
techniques and he's a great fan of the
first Earth battalion the first Earth
battalion remember was all about
teaching the American soldier to to have
inner peace to be wonderful I think the
first slide of the manual was the
American army has no what was the first
load of the burger
here we go the first line of the manual
was the US Army doesn't really have any
serious alternative than to be wonderful
and then disclaimer read this does not
comprise an official position by the
military as of now but then over the
years I think as the army recovered its
strength after Vietnam they began to see
that Jim's ideas could be used to hurt
people rather than heal them and those
are the ideas that live on today and I'm
just going to read a little bit and then
I think maybe we should move on to
questions from Pete Brousseau Peters
Pete teaches martial arts to the Marines
Peter's a pragmatist
he's an admirer of the first Earth
battalion but he's taken it upon himself
to adapt Jim's ideas into practical
applications for the battlefield Marine
I asked Pete to give me an example of a
practical application okay he said
there's a gang of insurgents standing in
front of you you are alone you want to
dissuade them from attacking you what do
you do I told Pete I didn't know he'd
said that the answer lay in the psychic
realm specifically the use of visual
aesthetics to instill psychically in the
enemy a disincentive to attack can you
be more explicit I asked okay said Pete
what you do is you grab one of them rip
out his eyeballs and stab him in the
neck the blood squirts out like a
fountain really a fountain get the blood
to spurt all over his friends I should
explain that Pete was saying this in a
slightly less effeminate manner just
punish the bejesus out of him right
there in front of his friends okay I
said oh go for the lungs said Pete
create a gaping chest wound what you
have done is lots of sucking in air and
lots of frothing or scrape a knife
across the face here's a clever thing
get your knife inside the clavicle
that's the collarbone once you're in
there you can scrape most of the tissue
away from that side of the neck separate
his brain stem from the back of his neck
doesn't take much movement physics wise
Pete paused what I'm doing is he is
creating a powerful visual psychic
disincentive for the other insurgents to
attack me Peter and his music up loud
that's er I shouted what shouted Pete
broad interpretation of Jim's ideals I
yelled he'd turned his music down again
and shrugged as if to say there you go
that's warfare now my belief is that
these ideas live on in such a way that
is very representative of the way that
the military works it's a think tank
when the Abu Ghraib photographs came out
everybody was asking the question who
gave the orders how high up does this go
I think it was the wrong question I
think you need to look at what happened
at Waco Texas to understand what
happened at Guantanamo Bay and at Abu
Ghraib and basically these are like
laboratories it's very very rare that
the US Army has the opportunity to have
a bunch of people surrounded they try
stuff out this is out this is why some
of Jim's ideas like the musical torture
and so on these half-remembered ideas
from think-tank meetings of days gone by
these ideas that have that have that
have sort of stuck and festered in the
dingy and unsatisfactory world of the
theoretical and suddenly they've got
opportunity to rather stuff into you
know to put this stuff into practice and
at Waco instantly they were trying out
all these crazy ideas you know they flew
in a Moscow scientist who was an expert
in subliminal sounds which was another
one of Jim's ideas they were going to
get Charlton Heston to play the voice of
God - - and mix it underneath Nancy
Sinatra which they were blasting at the
Abbey Church and Charlton Heston would
you know presumably say this is God
surrender and the only reason why it
didn't happen was that
psyops who were in charge of this and
Colonel John Alexander who felt in this
story earlier was in charge of this they
wanted the Moscow scientists I go
Smirnoff to take full responsibility if
anything went wrong and I go Smirnoff
refused so they never put that into
practice but what you see is all these
non-lethal technologies you see all
these kind of nutty ideologies all
battling for supremacy like a kind of
casserole of ideas outside the church at
Waco and
from the from the former detainees at
Guantanamo Bay I've interviewed it seems
that exactly the same thing was going on
there said to a man called Jamal how
al-harith
how do you how do you feel you know how
did you feel at Guantanamo Bay he said I
felt like a laboratory wrapped so I felt
that they were trying stuff out on me
and we know that the history of the army
I mean in in in this room is Erik Olson
who's whose father was was was victim to
two of these think-tank II ideas one
known as MKULTRA where they would put
LSD in to the Cointreau of unsuspecting
guinea pigs and Eric's father was was
one of those people and also another
think tank II program called artichoke
where they would inject heroin into into
the people they were detaining and then
withdraw them and they were testing out
cold turkey techniques and so on and
ex-father got mixed up in that as father
ended up being well the CIA say that he
was inadvertently spiked with LSD and he
had a bad trip and he jumped out the
window
but Eric spent the last fifty years
investigating and has come to the
conclusion that his father was pushed
out the window because he was involved
in another one of these esoteric
think-tank II ideas where people died
and he was going to spill the beans he
had a crisis of conscience like Martin
Luther and so they threw him out the
window so the history of the military
when you look at those Abu Ghraib
photographs you know I think you don't
see holiday snaps what you see is the
result of ideas like the ideas that
began with the first Earth battalion
that have become skewed and distorted
over three decades into something that
can destroy people rather than heal them
and one example is with Barney the
purple dinosaur when it was announced a
year ago that that they were rounding up
prisoners of war in Iraq and blaster
land with Barney the purple dinosaur it
was treated as a funny story because you
know bye-bye
the major news networks in America we've
all had to listen to Barney those of us
have had kids you know torch is not that
bad
it was disseminated as a funny story
because who wants to replace a funny
story as Eric once said to me with a
story that's not fun and in fact I'm
going to read one more tiny bit from
this before we move on to questions I
saw I was given seven photographs over
of a detainee who just been given the
Barney treatment as they called it it's
48 hours of Barney with a flushing
strobe light inside a shipping container
in the desert heat I mean this was the
funny story of the of the war
and I once did an event with Fay World
and she said to me should put little
yellow post-it notes in the bits where
you want to read I thought that we crazy
what do you know Fay Weldon okay so this
is a description of the photograph of
the man who'd just been given the Barney
treatment you know another modern-day
incarnation of the ideas that began in
this rather lovely Californian way with
the first Earth battalion the detainee
is inside the shipping container he is
barefoot a thin plastic strap binds his
ankles and he's crouched in the corner
up against the silver corrugated wall
the metal floor is covered with brown
dust and pools of liquid right at the
back of the shipping container deep in
the shadows you can just make out the
figure of another detainee lying in a
huddle on the floor his face masked by a
hood now the rag only covers the first
man's eyes so you can only see his face
which is deeply lined like an old man's
but his wispy moustache reveals that
he's probably around 17 he's wearing a
torn white undershirt covered with
yellow and brown stains there's an open
wound on one of his skinny arms and
above it someone has written a number
with a black marker pen he might have
done terrible things I know nothing
about him other than these seven
fragments of his life but I can say this
in the last photograph he is screaming
so hard it almost looks as if he's
laughing anyway I'm not cheering out any
questions oh yes if you have questions
would you step up to the microphone hi
hi I'll start first listening to you
talk and I heard you on the on the Kojo
and Andy Shore earlier yesterday today
so it's very interesting the the
conclusion I draw is that you seem to
say that there's really no real
distinction between say what the US
military are doing in terms of
experiments and perhaps what the Nazis
did during the Second World War the
horrible experiments we've heard in the
concentration camps you know that
josef mengele not to not to forget also
that this kind of research is I
understand it I think Geller is one of
the people that's talked about it the
Soviets we're certainly doing something
like that and I and I believe the
Chinese also and Saddam Hussein for all
I've heard about do you draw any moral
distinctions in terms of the motivations
between say what the American military
might be doing and my follow-on to that
question is you mentioned earlier that
there was no sense of hierarchical
responsibility for this it do you
conclude that the higher levels of the
military say at the very highest senior
levels or members of Congress set
supervise the military establishment
condone this or they're simply out to
lunch and don't know about this hmm
well answer to your first question I do
see a distinction because I I think at
the heart of even the most grotesque of
the abuses in Iraq is in their minds
it's better than killing people and and
the the whole point of the first Earth
battalion was it was a very warm hearted
endeavor it was all to do with averting
future Wars it's got skewed and
distorted by yeah I used to think the
American soldier but now I think human
nature into something that can be used
to shatter rather than heal but it was a
very positive and warm spirited people
the people in this book I don't think
essentially the baddies I think I think
the people in this book of good is that
there are exceptions and only the main
exception is is the case of MKULTRA an
operation artichoke which I hope it
doesn't matter just constantly pointing
in but which Eric's father was a victim
to I mean that's that's one example of a
time when it manifested itself in a very
unworn hearted manner but in general
these are people trying to do good and
I'll give you one example one of Jim's
ideas was that military scientists
should journey to the furthest corners
of their imagination in a
in a quest to invent a new kind of
weapon that was that was big hearted and
non-lethal now some of the weapons that
they invented kind of nuts I mean as the
gay gasps two people know about the gay
gasps they drop they spend a lot of time
and money on this
you drop a gas on the enemy that would
turn them gay and at the same time you
drop a halitosis gas so the enemy would
be both attracted to one another and
also repelled and it'd be so freaked out
by this that the Americans would just go
in and take over without anyone getting
hurt so they spent a lot of time on the
gun the gay bomb they spend a lot of
time on the sticky foam which which was
in The Hulk movie if anybody's seen that
it was anything that could stop the Hulk
for a while but it was a real thing the
sticky foam it was basically you know
fire extinguisher and you'd spray it and
it would envelop somebody would foam and
then there'd be frozen to the spot and
this was actually deployed in Somalia
you know yet another real-life
incarnation of the first Earth battalion
the Somalis were trying to get to the
food and and some kind of riot broke out
so they released the sticky foam and
they sprayed it as a wall they didn't
spit onto the Somalis they spread it as
a wall between the Somalis and the food
and the Somalis all stood there kind of
waiting for to harden looking a bit
befuddled and then they climbed over it
encoded on rioting that was that was the
first and last time that the sticky film
was ever deployed in a combat situation
there's the hologram of Allah they've
been attempting to develop these are all
ideas nurtured by this kernel kernel
alexandra's as a result of being
inspired by by Jim Shannon and the first
Earth battalion the hologram of Allah
would be projected over an enemy Capitol
and presumably Allah would then say it
turns out that America isn't the Great
Satan I guess but then there's some
real-world incarnations of this this
work done by Colonel Alexander as a
result of the first Earth battalion and
one of them is that is the taser gun the
taser gun was nurtured into being by the
colonel and I mean I know it's a
controversial weapon and people
have died but imagine how many lives
have been saved as a result of the tase
again so so now I see this book as a
book full of good people and in the same
way that I see them as being a book
which D demonizes the demons and in
response to your second question it's
it's it's a tricky one to answer the
general that the current chief of staff
of the US Army is a man called general
Pete shoemaker who is a great friend and
fan of Jim Channon
and the first Earth battalion and he was
brought back from retirement by Donald
Rumsfeld and he's well known to have an
interest in these paranormal esoteric
military pursuits he was at Fort Bragg
around the time at this commanding
Special Forces when they were staring at
goats he's brought him back from
retirement to to teach majors some of
the first Earth battalion techniques so
now is a time when I know that these
ideas go to the very top the Abu Ghraib
photographs all you can do is hazard a
guess I mean Lindy England you know the
young girl in the photographs is always
asserted that they weren't holiday snaps
they were you know military intelligence
which is you know where these ideas
really take root said you know keep
going is getting what we need is getting
what we need but my guess is that as I
say it's a places like Guantanamo Abu
Ghraib or a casserole of ideas where
people are desperately trying to get
elbow room to try the thing that they
remember from the think tank meeting of
15 years ago out middle ranking people
any other questions
thanks John oh you let somebody off
thanks oh you know it's very hard to
believe as you read that this is where
any of it is actual it just has the feel
of a put-on that's so bizarre right okay
I accept that it's actual can I say
that's because we still invest in our
leaders some kind of sagacity and
rational thought and and in fact this
is saying but you know is it such a
surprise that they're just as nuts as we
are well I don't invest any trust in our
leaders and think of them as sagacious
but I don't know what I mean the the
follow-on to the question about the
benign an intent of the people of doing
this to me that sounds absurd there's
always a certain benignity when people
decide to kill other people to win
Sherman and the Civil War invented the
idea of attacking the civilian
population to persuade the sons and
mothers and daughters of the Confederacy
not to support the war grant decided to
kill a lot of people just calculating
that he could kill more people than they
could write quite a separate idea is
written about in a book called the
sociopath next door that just came out
and is available here in which he also
claims that 4% of the population of
sociopaths what is the likelihood of
these people ending up in those
positions because the essence of the
whole thing is to be able to kill
somebody and destroy somebody defeat
somebody hurts somebody without feeling
guilty more responsible well in terms of
how benign and how malignant these ideas
are these specific ideas began in a
benign place as there's no doubt about
it the people they the Guru's and the
shaman's in the early 1980s who bought
these paranormal pursuits into the
military and intelligence communities
were doing it in a benign manner now
when a more malevolent person gets hold
of these ideas and sees that they can be
twisted and used in a malevolent manner
they become malevolent but you know the
the introduction into the military of
these ideas were done from a from a
benign place hey first of all I'd like
to say I'm very impressed by booking I
thought you gave great presentation oh
thank you very much what holds out ah I
did want to mention first of all there's
a group there's a website I just found
out about called educate
- yourself gorg that has a lot of
scientific links and papers presented
about the MKULTRA and the especially
what the Kinnick ohm group that national
security no such agency at Fort Meade
does and they talk about using the e.l.f
and infrasound and using cell phone
transponders they up set down antennas
from to beam certain frequencies that
cause disabling with a calcium channel
efflux in your body immune weakening
disease states paranoia
they found they've isolated brainwave
patterns of psychopaths and they sort of
broadcast them through so try and fact
healthy people um and that's a tip of
the iceberg I've seen certain things
through this it was also talked about
the connection with Wilhelm Reich and
how the cell phone based on what why but
there's also thing when you mentioned
the mock human sacrifice not God can't
say what happens at Bohemian Grove but
just here in Washington I know for a
fact that there have been black masses
done um the one you heard about a
kayaker the guy was right here by
mantras park off MacArthur Boulevard he
was digging his dog took a dump and dug
up this human skeleton and later
identified as a kayaker so uh you know
we're supposed to believe that a kayaker
drowned in the middle of the forest four
hundred yards from the water um I'm not
gonna tell you who I know what whose
basement it happened in I'm not gonna
get into any of that but I'll just gonna
say it's it's the most sick individual
thing and uh also one more thing I'd
like to add was that they were the
gallon org that exfiltrated the ratline
you know 300,000 of the worst Nazis
including Mangala many of them were
brought in through the CIA and they were
basic still on this guy
pero PE ro has a section on that site he
talks about his case but um I don't know
how accurate his is but worth reading
anyway um these nasty networks have been
part were brought in to you know to our
CIA and this is all because all public
records have been documented and they
unfortunately these are the people
who've taken technology such as
radionics which originally a wonderful
healing technology and turn them into
remote killing technology well one of
the things you spoke of the one that I
have some knowledge of is the
frequencies and and you know I you can
follow
a trail of patents like footprints in
the snow and the patrons sometimes
vanish into the world of military
classification and you know there's many
patents brought up by a man called
Oliver Lowry dr. Oliver Lowe from
Atlanta I turned up at his house one
time and and he really freaked me out
actually and so we we know that these
patents have been bought out by them by
the military and and you know the the
detainees at Guantanamo I've spoken to
speak of being blasted with with
frequencies you know put inside music I
low frequencies masked with music I
think there's no doubt that that they're
experimenting with this stuff and to add
a controversial suggestion I think
there's a good chance that even though
they're trying to stuff out it's not
necessarily true that it works you know
a lot of this stuff doesn't doesn't work
this may or may not work I don't know
psychotronic generators and
unfortunately they can be used to
amplify the power of those who aren't
martial art masters just satanic
perverts and they amplified enough to I
don't know how successful it has been
but they they try to give basically non
masters the power to kill somebody with
a side generator and unfortunately you
know uh that's a whole other story I
don't want yeah thank you
any other questions
I'm not quite sure how to phrase this in
a question but I'll try um I didn't read
your first book I have heard this one
and it seems that you know a lot of this
a lot of people are going I can't
believe what I'm reading or I can't
really be this it seems there's a huge
absurdist factor and a lot of what you
do and so some people have almost
labeled you as humorous in your
depiction of this stuff and I notice a
lot of writing is tinged with humor but
always comes back to a serious point um
because I think we can be absurd I think
absurdity is a natural human character
change think of how to Fraser to the
question but the question is do you
think the humor in your work comes from
the absurdness of the human race and how
all these things are implementing and
that's just your funneling of the facts
or do you use it as a coping mechanism
because some of the stuff is so
disturbing if you sort of stopped and
look at it out of context the only way
to deal with it is to laugh I think a
bit of both but you know when stuff get
you know when when when the story turns
dark I I take the jokes out and and I
did that in my first book two of them I
mean there's my section about you know
what happened to the Weaver family up in
Idaho you know it's no laughing matter
that's the point of the places where the
conspiracy theories come true when the
FBI will surround a family and shoot a
mother in the head and and and a young
child you know that's that's that's the
kind of place where the crazy people
suddenly don't seem so crazy
and where the government begins and
begins acting like a kind of grotesque
caricature of the way that the
conspiracy theorists see them but but in
general I I know I just I I I like to
find human situations human an absurdity
I consider myself you know vaguely
absurd person I don't distance myself
and the people I write about because I
think we're all capable of getting into
one of those bubbles of illogicality
we're within the bubbler or makes
absolute sense but from the outside
there's a chapter in them about David
Icke who goes around the world saying
that the shadowy cabal are actually
12-foot lizards who've taken human form
and then you've got the anti-defamation
league and various other anti-racist
groups saying are well when David Icke
says the 12-foot lizards
the world is actually using code and
what he means is a Jew's rule the world
and David axe is known I really do mean
lizards the ADL say are well that's code
two and you know I challenge anyone to
spend three or four weeks with David
Icke on the road and not come away
thinking just a little bit that maybe
12-foot lizards do rule the world
and of course both belief systems he
really does mean lizards those belief
systems are just as nuts as each other
so you know I find that absurdity an
embarrassment uh you know quite often as
as as powerful guiding forces in life is
love and tragedy and speaking personally
yeah I mean my mind manifests itself in
really dull domestic ways you know if I
can't reach my wife on the phone you
know it's clear that she's falling
downstairs and my son is now reaching up
for the flex of a newly boil kettle you
know thank you further I'm sorry wasn't
better phrase question but thank you for
K unopened thank you alright
you'd be the bad guy and turn it over to
the signing
I'm I'd like to thank John for coming
you can applaud it's one quick thing the
evil cabal of retail must take over as I
point out that we have copies of the men
who stare at goats and John's first book
that oh good good
adventures with extremists upfront and
actually when it first came out it was
one of our staff picks as well oh thank
you dude can I just say how glad I am to
see that you all seemed so nice when I
was coming how is thinking I must be
talking to those fat cats from
Washington DC I've heard so much about
but actually all seem to be lovely I
guess this isn't right um and John is
available to you know shake hands kiss
babies and sign books